المترجم: Rouaa Ez Edeen
المدقّق: muhammad Samir
ستّة
أربعة
اثنان
خمسة
أعداد سهلة جميعنا نعرفها،
وجميعنا نستخدمها في حياتنا اليومية.
ولكن ،هل جميعنا قادرين على
قراءة ما وراء الرقم.
وندرك معناه الحقيقي
وإسقاطاته على أرض الواقع
هذه سبعة،
إذا تركناها لوحدها، ستبقى سبعة.
إذا أزحناها قليلًا، تصبح سبعين.
إزا أزحناها قيلًا أيضًا، تصبح سبعمائة.
السبعة هي السبعة ذاتها لم تتغير،
ولكن قيمتها ومعناها، اختلف اختلافًا تامًا.
واختلافًا كبيرًا جدًا.
وهذا الكلام ينطبق على كلّ الأعداد،
وكلّ الأرقام.
مثلًا ،هذه نسبة مئوية 10%
من الممكن أن تكون معدل بطالة ،
أو أن تكون حسمًا على أسعار ملابس في العيد.
هذا الرقم الكبير،
من الممكن أن يخطر لكم أنه رقم هاتف.
أو من الممكن أن يكون رصيدي في البنك.
(ضحك)
ولكن، حقيقةً هذا الرقم
هوعدد سكان العالم حاليًا.
عددٌ كبيرٌ،أجل ،كبيرٌ جدًا
على هذا الكوكب الصغير
يوجد ما يقارب سبعة ونصف مليار نسمة
السبعة ونصف، ليست مجرّد رقم.
إنّهم سبعة ونصف مليار إنسان،
كلّ واحد منهم، له احتياجاته،
له متطلباته وله استهلاكه.
وبذات الوقت له أفعاله التي تؤثر على المحيط
من البيئة و من الناس الموجودين حوله.
سأخبركم،
قصّة السبعة ونصف مليار،
كيف وصلنا لهم مليارًا وراء مليار.
عام 1800 وهناك مصادر تقول 1803،
بلغ عدد سكان العالم المليار الأول.
عام 1800 أصبحنا مليار إنسان،
بعد 123 سنة ازددنا مليارًا جديدًا،
وهنا من الممكن أن نتفاجئ
بالمعلومة التي تليها.
أنّه فقط بعد 33سنة ازددنا مليارًا ثالثًا،
مفاجأة! أجل هناك مفاجأة أكبر.
لأنه فقط بعد 14 سنة ازددنا المليار الرابع.
وبعد 13 سنة ،ازددنا مليارًا جديدًا آخر
وفي هذا التاريخ،
في اليوم11في الشهر السابع سنة 1987،
بلغ سكان العالم 5 مليارات.
وهو اليوم العالمي للسكان يحتفل به من يومها
يوم 11 من الشهر السابع عام 1987
لمّا بلغ عدد سكان العالم 5 مليارات.
بعد 12 سنة ازددنا مليارًا جديدًا
وفي عام 2015، وصل عدد سكان العالم ل7 مليار
ومن المتوقع في عام2030 أن نصبح 8.5 مليار
إنه عدٌد كبير ،أجل
يوجد الكثير من الازدحام ،أجل
والناس لازالوا يتكاثرون ،ريثما نتحدث الآن
يزداد عدد سكان العالم
البارحة قد ازداد العدد، وغدًا سيزداد
ولكن هل الكوكب يكبر أيضُا؟
هل موارد الكوكب ستحتمل
هذه الزيادة السكانية الكبيرة ؟
هذا الانفجار السكاني ؟
بالطبع إن صحّت التسمية!
هل موارد الطبيعة ستحتمل
تصرفاتنا الجائرة بحقها؟
هل ستحتمل تصرفاتنا المجرمة
والبشعة وازدحامنا ؟
ربما الإنسان حاليًا،هو
أحد الكائنات الغير مهددة بالانقراض.
ربما بسبب نشاطاته وأفعاله و تصرفاته،
هو مهدِّد لللآخرين من الكائنات الحّية
الموجودة بالانقراض
وسبب لانقراض كائنات أخرى.
لذلك وجب علينا أن نضبط
ونسيطرعلى تصرفاتنا،
وأن نضبط ونسيطرعلى تزايد أعدادنا الهائلة.
لأنّ هذا التزايد لا يؤثر فقط
على البيئة المحيطة من حولنا
بل يؤثر أيضًا على علاقتنا ببعضنا،
وعلى اقتتالناعلى الموارد
التي سنزدحم على استخدامها.
موارد المياه وموارد الطاقة وموارد الغذاء
وهي أهم حاجات الإنسان ليبقى على قيد الحياة
هذا الخطر المحدق بالبشرية
قد لاحظه الناس منذ زمن،
وكان هناك عدد من الحلول
التي طُرحت لمواجهة هذه الزيادة الكبيرة،
ولوضع حدّ لهذا التزايد.
وقد ترون الكثيرمن الآراء الغريبة
التي طرحت عبر التاريخ.
أحد هذه الآراء، كان إيقاف الزواج
توقفوا عن إنجاب الأطفال!
وحتى كانت إحدى المدارس
التي تسمى المدرسة الماخوسية،
هي للعالم ماخوس
الذي قال،
بأنه على الفئات الفقيرة من الشعوب
ألّا تتزوج لأنها
غير قادرة على إعالة أبنائها.
في حين ،
ظهرت مدارس أخرى أذكى وأحدث
قدمت حلول أخرى مثل أن نضع
حدًا معينًا لأبناء كل أسرة
كل أسرة يحق لها إنجاب عدد محدّد من الأبناء
ويوجد حلول أحدث وأكثر وعيًا وعلميّة
تتمثل بوعي مجتمعي كامل
سنتحدث عنها.
بما يتعلق بالسيطرة
على عدد السكان العالمي وتزايده،
هناك دائمًا خلط بين أمرين مهمّين،
ومصطلحين مشهورين كثيرًا.
ونحن نادرًا ما نلاحظ الفرق بينهما
وهما تحديد النسل وتنظيم الأسرة.
من الذي يعرف الفرق بينهما، فليرفع يده
ومن الذي يعتبرهما الشيء ذاته،
فليرفع يده أيضًا
من يعتبرهما ذات الشيء؟
إذا استوقفك أحدهم في الطريق وسألك :
هل تحديد النسل مفيد للصحّة؟ بماذا تجيبه؟
أو ما هو تحديد النسل؟
هناك فرق كبير جدًا بينهما
تحديد النسل، هو عبارة عن قانون
تحديد النسل يحدّد لأسرتك
عددًا معينًا من الأطفال
قد يكون واحد أو اثنان
بقوّة القانون ليس بإمكانك أن تخالفه
أو أن تنجب أكثر
أي إنجاب لطفل زيادة
على الحد القانوني المحدّد لك
أنت في مشكلة، فقد خالفت القانون.
أما بما يتعلق بتنظيم الأسرة،
فهو عبارة عن وعي،
تتم زراعته في المجتمع ككل.
وعي تام بأنه لا يجب إنجاب الأطفال بكثرة
أي لا يجب إنجاب الأطفال بلا وعي
وأنا لا أعي مدى قدرتي على إطعامهم،
ولا مدى قدرتي على تأمين الحياة الكريمة لهم
تنظيم الأسرة لا يحدّد لك عددًا معينًا
من الأطفال.
أنت بوعيك وإدراكك لقدراتك الماديّة
وإمكانياتك تحدّد ذلك لوحدك
إضافة لذلك، هل المشكلة حقيقةً بعدد السكان؟
أم المشكلة بنوعية هؤلاء السكان؟
إذا تواجد لدينا،
سكان واعين ومنتجين ومثقفين ومتعلمين.
أين المشكلة؟ فليزد الله من أمثالهم
المشكلة في وجود عدد
من الناس العالة على المجتمع
الغير قادرين على الإنتاج،
الغير قادرين على إعالة أنفسهم.
بل هم سبب في تعرقل
سير عملية التنمية في المجتمع.
تنظيم الأسرة،
لم هو مهم وضروري ؟
ولم أساسي؟ لأسباب عديدة.
أولها، لأنني إن أنجبت أولادي بكثرة
بعد 3 أو 4 سنوات صار لدي 3 أو 4 أولاد
هؤلاء الأطفال كلهم يرضعون
أي سأحضر لهم الحليب معًا
أي سأشتري لهم الملابس كلهم معًا
أي سيدخلون المدرسة كلهم معًا
أي سأدفع لهم جميعًا معًا
بالتالي، النفقات تزايدت كثيرًا على الأسرة
إضافةً لذلك ،استنزاف لصحة الأم بشكل كبير
إضافة لذلك،
لا أحد من هؤلاء الأطفال تحققت له
الرعاية والاهتمام المناسب
لا أحد منهم قد حقق أساسًا
فترة الرضاعة الطبيعية والتي هي سنتان
فتنظيم الأسرة، يعني أن تنجب الأطفال
ولكن بفترات زمنية متباعدة
بحيث كل طفل يتحقق له الرعاية الطبية
والاهتمام والعناية
وفترة الرضاعة الطبيعية كاملة له
لأنها تؤثرعلى صحته
لذلك، تنظيم الأسرة يعني
إذا كنت مدركًا لعدم قدرتي
على إنجاب سبعة أطفال
وتقديم الحياة الكريمة لهم
وتأمين مستوى لائق من الحياة لهم
وتأمين تعليم مناسب
وإعدادهم كمثقفين واعين ومتعلمين
إذا ،فأنا يجب ألّا أنجبهم
لأنني إن أنجبتهم سأكون قد ظلمتهم
إذا كنت مدركًا لقدرتي على إنجاب طفلين
متعلّمين مثقفين
مؤمن لهم كافة وسائل الرفاهية
والرّاحة والحياة الكريمة
أنا في هذه الحالة أستطيع إنجابهم
إذًا، هذا هو الفرق ما بين
تحديد النسل وتنظيم الأسرة.
الشيء الذي سنتكلم عنه كشباب،
دورنا كشباب كون غالبيتنا شباب.
وأساسًا ،كون مجتمعنا مجتمع فتي
مجتمع شاب
حاليًا شباب وشابّات،
مستقبلًا آباء وأمهات.
مسؤوليتنا أن نحمل هذا الفكر
ونحمل هذا الوعي
أن ننجب أطفالًا بالمقدار الذي بوسعنا
تأمين حياة كريمة لنا ولهم
بحيث أن يكونوا فاعلين في المجتمع ومتعلّمين
وأن يكونوا مصدر فخر لك
هذا كل شيء.
(تصفيق)